sur sensation
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zone Europe
sur Radio sensation et sur TV 78 c'est
une émission spéciale réalisée à Berlin
Berlin première ville de l'UE capitale
de l'Allemagne un pays membre de l'Union
européenne depuis 1958 de l'espace
Schengen depuis 1995 et qui a adopté
l'euro le premier janvier 1999 à travers
cette émission je vais vous parler de
politique d'environnement et aussi de
culture
je vais également vous faire découvrir
Berlin
[Musique]
er
l'Allemagne c'est l'un des membres
fondateurs de l'Union européenne le
couple franco-allemand a été on le sait
tous le moteur de cette construction et
pourtant français et allemand ne partage
pas le même attachement à l'Europe la
guerre en Ukraine a renforcé le soutien
de l'opinion publique a lieu 48% des
Français ont une image positive de
l'Union européenne contre 56% des
Allemands on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi avec Pascal Thibault
correspondant de Radio France
Internationale en Allemagne
sur une Europe
bonjour Pascal Thibault bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous recevoir ici dans votre
bureau à Berlin alors l'Union européenne
a eu des moments difficiles ces
dernières années on pense à la crise
grecque on pense aussi au brexit mais
récemment avec le covid avec la guerre
en Ukraine on a le sentiment que l'UE
c'est un peu ressoudé on parle même
d'intégration de d'intégrer de nouveaux
pays maintenant l'Albanie la Macédoine
du Nord voire même l'Ukraine des choses
qui pensaient qui paraissaient
improbables il y a encore quelques
années
quel est le point de vue des Allemands
sur l'Union européenne est-ce qu'il a
changé depuis les 10 dernières années
alors ce qu'on peut dire c'est que bon
l'Allemagne reste quand on a notamment
les sondages qui sont faits notamment
les sondages au baromètre restent un
pays où le la défense des valeurs
européennes des institutions européennes
de l'intégration européenne reste fort
plus fort que en France je crois où il y
a plus de résistance d'angoisse de peur
etc ça ça demeure au sein de la
population
on a aussi une grande différence par
rapport à la France on l'a vu aussi lors
des dernières élections de septembre
dernier comparé au récentes
présidentielles et parlementaires en
France et législatives c'est qu'on a une
très large partie de l'électorat et des
parties représentées qui soutiennent
qui soutiennent une plus forte
intégration européenne à l'exception de
l'extrême droite et du Parti de Gauche
qui qui ont perdu qui ont perdu un peu
de la superbe donc ça c'est déjà les
conditions un peu de base actuellement
effectivement avec on a vu que
après des phases où il y a eu beaucoup
plus de tension de de tension et de
force
centrifuge en Europe avec la crise de la
zone euro l'Allemagne qui est
extrêmement critiquée notamment dans les
pays du Sud le départ d'un des pays
effectivement le brexit qu'on a
effectivement avec les les deux crises
les plus récentes la crise sanitaire du
covid et actuellement la guerre en
Ukraine plutôt au contraire une un
rapprochement une union qui semble
fonctionner des avancées importantes
avec notamment la mutualisation d'une
partie des dettes avec un pas important
franchi par l'Allemagne il y a deux ans
là-dessus alors que une chancelière
chrétienne démocrate était au pouvoir et
on l'avait aussi que la solidarité avec
des nuances reste quand même forte dans
dans les prises de position face à
Poutine et dans la crise énergétique
pour laquelle l'Allemagne et et au
premier rang bien évidemment raison ça
dépendances traditionnelle par rapport à
la Russie sur la l'intégration que
pensent les Allemands notamment de l'UE
et des projets alors je pense que les
Allemands restent je le disais déjà
plutôt favorable à une plus grande
intégration européenne très longtemps
l'Europe a été ça vaut surtout pour les
décennies d'après-guerre un peu
l'erzat de
de nations pour les Allemands pour qui
tout ce qui était national est
évidemment Oni et en raison en raison de
l'héritage du Troisième Reich bon
maintenant 80 ans après la distance est
un petit peu plus grande par rapport à
ce passé mais on voit quand même une
adhésion importante aux valeurs aux
valeurs européennes et une plus grande
intégration et on a vu notamment au
niveau cette fois-ci politique pas
uniquement la population ces dernières
semaines un chancelier Scholtz 13 en
avant pour
aller dans les quand est soutenir
l'intégration de de ces pays où la
perspective d'intégration de ces pays à
l'Union européenne estimant que
peut-être on les a fait un petit peu
trop patienté dans l'antichambre et que
le risque était peut-être qu'ils aillent
qu'ils aillent voir ailleurs
voilà et puis effectivement vous l'avez
mentionné le fait c'est assez
effectivement historique que on a donné
une perspective européenne à l'Ukraine
ce qui évidemment n'aurait pas eu lieu
sans la sans la guerre alors justement
l'année dernière l'Allemagne a changé le
gouvernement on est passé d'Angela
Merkel la Cedeo à la Schulz plutôt à
gauche quels sont les principaux
changements qu'il va apporter à
l'Allemagne et est-ce que ça peut
changer les relations franco-allemandes
surtout sur la politique européenne il y
a pas un changement radical dans la
mesure encore une fois ou l'essentiel
des forces politiques à l'exception des
deux extrêmes restes pro-européennes il
y a effectivement des nuances dans la
mesure où et ça vaut surtout pour le
parti de du chancelier Olaf schols les
sociaux-démocrates les Verts on a des
forces qui sont sans doute plus
favorables que les chrétiens démocrates
à une plus grande intégration des
abandons de souveraineté
et qui sont sans doute aussi plus
favorables et là évidemment ça fait écho
à ce qu'on peut entendre en France par
exemple à une mutualisation
supplémentaire des dettes
sur différents sujets et notamment le
dernier que j'évoquais
il y a en revanche des divergences au
sein de la coalition actuellement au
pouvoir entre ces deux parties vers
socio-démocrates et le Parti libéral qui
même s'il a évolué par rapport à des
positions antérieures extrêmement
disons rigides sur les principes
libéraux d'orthodoxie budgétaire reste
quand même très réticent à une plus
grande mutualisation des têtes à une
intégration qui signifierait aussi une
solidarité financière donc c'est là que
ça ça devient un petit peu compliqué en
interne et que ça rend la coopération
avec d'autres pays lorsque des
initiatives peuvent être mises sur sur
la table peut-être un peu plus compliqué
mais on voit que
le compromis étant une des bases des une
des bases des des
politiques allemandes le Parti libéral
même si actuellement il a un petit peu
en effectuant les sondages donc il
cherche d'autant plus à défendre son
identité ses points de vue
traditionnels on voit que lui aussi est
prêt et devra sans doute mettre un petit
peu d'eau dans sa bière dans la prise de
conscience des enjeux européens elle
passe aussi par les médias on le sait
les Allemands ont énormément plus de
correspondants en Allemagne que les
Français comment on traite l'actualité
européenne ici est-ce qu'il y a des
différences avec le traitement que l'on
fait en France
alors effectivement il y a je connais
pas les chiffres actuels mais je sais
qu'il y a une décrue des du nombre de
correspondants français qui a toujours
un nombre important de correspondant
allemand même de médias dit peut-être
pas enfin qui ne sont pas peut-être en
première division dirons-nous il y a des
bureaux importants notamment de des
médias publics qui ont plus de moyens
aussi en Allemagne qu'en France
c'est plus présent les la couverture de
la de l'actualité européenne dans les
médias allemands
pour commencer par les médias
audiovisuels c'est certainement le cas
on sait que dans la télé en France
l'Europe à l'image être un peu ennuyeux
de pas fournir des images très glamour
et que on va peut-être privilégier
des images des reportages etc dans les
JT qui soit un petit peu plus imagés et
un peu plus qui puisse visuel un peu
plus visuel voilà ici c'est vrai qu'on a
notamment dans la télévision publique
encore une
on a encore l'idée que
d'abord c'est le contenu qui prit le
contenu prime sur l'image je simplifie
un petit peu et c'est vrai que du coup
on a aussi des images un petit peu
répétitives
de défiler de limousine qui arrive de
personnes qui se dirigent vers un micro
et qui prennent la parole et qui sont
évidemment un petit peu répétitives il y
a aussi magazine européen il y en a à la
télévision il y en a sur tel ou telle
radio public
à des heures d'écoute
descentes dirons-nous est-ce que je
disais là vous aussi pour la vous aussi
je crois après faudra faire des études
savantes pour la presse écrite où il y a
plus de correspondants et une plus
grande couverture de l'Union européenne
alors ça ça c'est sans doute lié à la
culture politique qu'on a évoqué avant
je pense que c'est dû au fait qu'il y a
plus de correspondants c'est voilà il y
a sans doute le poids de l'Allemagne en
Europe économiquement le fait que voilà
ce qui se passe à Bruxelles et
sur un porte pour tout le monde
peut-être encore plus important pour eux
on pense aux conséquences que peuvent
avoir tel ou tel décision pour
l'industrie automobile par exemple
lorsqu'il s'agit des émissions de CO2
pour ne citer qu'un exemple enfin tous
avec une couverture assez importante on
pourrait peut-être ajouter qu'on a aussi
une présence de leaders de responsable
allemand de premier plan dans les
instances européennes
ancienne ministre
donc la Merkel mais aussi Manfred Viber
qui a dirigé le Parlement européen etc
qui a été qui était tête de liste des et
qui dirige maintenant le Parti populaire
européen et bien merci beaucoup Pascal
Thibault d'avoir été avec nous dans une
Europe je rappelle que vous êtes le
correspondant de Radio France
Internationale ici à Berlin
Berlin est souvent connu pour être l'une
des villes les plus gai friendly
d'Europe j'ai rendez-vous avec Gaëlle
Boudjema il est originaire de la région
parisienne et il est venu s'installer
ici à Berlin c'est le président de bleu
blanc rose une association
franco-allemande LGBT à Berlin
bonjour Gaëlle Boudjema bonjour merci
d'être avec nous dans l'émission zone
Europe vous êtes donc installé à Berlin
depuis 2007 vous êtes aujourd'hui le
président de l'association bleu blanc
rose
quels sont les activités que vous faites
au quotidien avec cette association
alors la principale activité c'est une
stamtiche c'est un petit c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut pas traduire en
français c'est une rencontre qu'on se
fait tous les mois soit souvent dans un
resto pour manger des fois on peut que
boire aussi et donc là on fait au moins
une fois par mois ça les gens de
l'association donc en général il y a 15
à 20 personnes
et
donc ça c'est tous les mois et on des
fois on va dans le même endroit soit on
va dans le même endroit dans un bar dans
un cas fait qu'on connaît souvent le gay
ou soit soit on change on essaie de
changer quand même sous de temps en
temps c'est donc une association
franco-allemande il y a aussi des
Français des Allemands dans
l'association en fait c'est francophone
on dit il y a des Belges il y a des
Canadiens il y a de tout francophone
dans le sens où c'est les Allemands qui
aiment bien la France et tout ça on est
combien de personnes contre
l'association aujourd'hui en 2022 alors
ceux qui payent la cotisation il y en a
à peu près 100 personnes et ceux qui
sont qui reçoivent la newsletter c'est à
peu près 1000 c'est maintenant 15 ans
que vous êtes installé ici à Berlin
parce que vos meilleurs souvenirs avec
l'association alors l'association c'est
en fait c'est une c'est un truc qui se
passe tous les ans ça s'appelle la
straussd c'est toujours en fait tous les
ans avant le covid même de pendant le
covid il y avait une deux ans de pause
il y a une il y a une une semaine de la
Pride de la Gay Pride et en fait pendant
ce temps là c'est en fait c'est le ça
commence avec la strassenfest c'est une
fête de rue où toutes les associations
instant et les barres gays et tout ça et
donc là c'est en fait c'est ça c'est moi
c'est les meilleurs moments c'est ça
c'est pendant un week-end nous on a un
stand tous les ans et là on présente
notre association on fait on présente on
fait peut-être des petites activités sur
le stand qui ont par exemple un concours
de corde à sauter oui on fait un apéro
aussi donc c'est vraiment convivial et
c'est vraiment le truc local berlinois
et qu'on aime bien alors petit rappel
historique maintenant en Allemagne de
l'Est l'homosexualité a été dépénalisé
en 1967 et il a fallu deux ans de plus
pour que ce soit également le cas en RFA
depuis 2017 le mariage homosexuel et
légalisé en est autorisé en Allemagne
vous pouvez aussi donc les personnes
homosexuelles adopter un enfant ensemble
ce qui n'était pas possible avant
l'Allemagne est avec l'Espagne selon une
étude le pays où être homosexuel est le
plus accepté dans la société vous le
ressentez ici au quotidien bah je pense
que c'est c'est pas je pense que c'est
plus une question de ville c'est les
grandes villes c'est Berlin
effectivement Berlin c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment une ville hyper ouverte
et tout ça mais je pense que dès qu'on
se sent un peu de Berlin là on se sent
un peu je sais pas c'est pas qu'on se
sent mais on
voilà c'est pas c'est pas aussi top que
Berlin quoi et comment est-ce qu'on
explique qu'ici à Berlin
la ville soit plutôt geffrent comme
étant une des villes les plus gai frein
de l'Europe comment est-ce qu'on
l'explique je pense que c'est l'histoire
ça date c'était avant la avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale les années 20
ou c'était vraiment les années folles à
Berlin et c'est là tout a commencé les
balles et tout ça et je pense que c'est
pas c'est historique et ça ça continue
comme ça une ville ouverte une ville
ouverte à tout une ville où tout est
tout est libre on peut tout faire voilà
c'est tout le temps restait comme ça au
moment où nous enregistrons ça a été
mission c'est Louis c'est la semaine
après la Gay Pride ça s'est bien passé
cette année oui tout à fait comme d'hab
hop bon voilà il y a eu des petits des
petits soucis mais bon vraiment
l'ensemble était extraordinaire quoi et
quelles sont vos prochains combats
maintenant pour l'association
le prochain combat c'est bah en fait
c'est vrai que notre association est il
y a beaucoup de gens de plus de on va
dire plus de 35 ans et nous on aimerait
bien attirer des gens voilà les plus
jeunes genre 25 30 les petits jeunes qui
arrivent et tout ça mais bon c'est vrai
que le mieux associatif c'est plus une
question moi je sais que je suis rentré
dans le milieu associatif plus tard plus
vers 30 ans c'est vrai que quand on a 20
20 ans 25 ans est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
est intéressé par les associations
s'engager dans une association devenir
devenir membre d'une association
voilà c'est ça qui passe en priorité
merci beaucoup d'avoir été merci
Corentin merci de nous avoir entendu
d'avoir été avec nous dans un Europe
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
Berlin compte une centaine de théâtre
plus de 156 cinémas 170 musées et 350
galeries d'art la vie musicale y est
aussi très riche on y trouve également
de nombreuses activités à pratiquer
étaient comme hiver en histoire et
avant-garde quels sont les
incontournables j'ai rendez-vous avec
Carlo CARBONNET deux visites Berlin
Guten Tag car le carbone
merci beaucoup alors la première image
justement quand on quand on imagine
Berlin quand on la connaît pas très bien
c'est la porte de Brandebourg alors
cette porte elle symbolise cette ville
mais aussi même le reste de l'Allemagne
on s'y rassemble pour les fêtes de fin
d'année mais aussi pour voir les matchs
de la sélection allemande la manchaft
quelle est l'histoire de cette porte
commençons par un petit fait amusant à
propos de notre port de bambour car vous
le savez peut-être pas mais elle a un
lien avec l'un de vos héros
l'adresse de la porte de Brandebourg
c'est la place parisienne la parideur
plate c'est une petite anecdote amusante
pour les visiteurs français oui la porte
de Brandebourg est l'une des dernières
portes toujours intacte de la ville de
Berlin toutes les autres ont été
intégralement détruites ou non
reconstruite
autre fait amusant vous savez sur la
porte de Brandebourg nous avons le
quadridge c'est une magnifique statue
qui a été volée par notre ami Napoléon
Bonaparte en 1806 quand il a pris Berlin
mais huit ans après nous avons pu la
récupérer et la remettre à sa place
ensuite il y a deux choses importantes à
dire sur l'histoire contemporaine la
porte de Brandebourg a été durant des
années le symbole de la séparation de la
ville car nous nous souvenons tous des
images de porte de Brandebourg et de cet
horrible mur juste devant
et sur la partie ouest les escaliers ou
les personnalités politiques faisaient
leur discours comme Regan qui dénonçait
le mur
après 1989 la porte de Brandebourg est
devenue l'un des symboles de la chute du
Mur même si le mur n'a pas été
directement cassé à cet endroit mais
c'est le plus gros symbole pour ça et
bien sûr pour la réunification des deux
Allemagne après les premiers événements
de l'Allemagne réunifiée ce sont
déroulés près de la porte et encore
aujourd'hui l'événement du nouvel an à
la porte de Brandebourg est un des
rassemblements du Nouvel An le plus
important au monde
events Berlin est aussi connu dans le
monde entier pour son mur mais avant
d'être la capitale de l'Allemagne
c'était la capitale de la Prusse est-ce
qu'il y a encore des traces de l'époque
prussienne dans la ville soit
[Musique]
oui vous pouvez en trouver beaucoup et
aussi beaucoup de nouvelles choses que
nous avons intégré ces dernières années
au home Bolt forum le Humble forum il a
reconstruction de l'ancien château de
Berlin c'était le lieu dans lequel les
empereurs de l'Empire Prusse vivaient et
à l'intérieur c'est un forum culturel
maintenant vous pouvez y voir quelques
vestiges du bâtiment d'origine ce
dernier a été détruit à cause de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et il y a
toujours des expositions sur l'histoire
de cet endroit
ensuite nous avons plusieurs
organisations dans la ville qui gèrent
notre patrimoine culturel l'une très
célèbre et la Fondation des patrimoine
culturel Prussiens c'est un peu la mer
de la compagnie des musées de Berlin qui
est la responsable de l'île au musée
enfin vous pouvez aussi trouver
plusieurs châteaux et jardins de
l'époque
prussiennes qui sont gérés par la
Fondation des châteaux et jardins
Prussiens Foundation
en terme d'architecture vous en avez
parlé la ville a été en partie détruite
à la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
puis il y a eu la division avec le mur
entre l'Est et l'Ouest est-ce que cette
histoire se ressent toujours dans la
ville en termes d'architecture
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on y a encore
quelques traces de cela
et que la ville a été réunifiée
évidemment la ville a beaucoup changé
encore des différences architecturales
si vous allez assez loin côté est du
côté ouest il y a ces immeubles froids
qu'on appelle plat and boat qui sont de
typiques appartenants et allemands
tous similaires à l'intérieur
[Musique]
on peut aussi comparer les principales
avenues qui donnent une bonne idée des
différences architecturales par exemple
si vous allez à l'est sur l'avenue Karl
Marx qui était avant appelé l'avenue
Staline et que vous la comparez pas la
plus grande avenue du côté ouest la
confiture standham c'est complètement
deux mondes différents
et d'un point de vue culturel Berlin est
connu aussi pour son île au musée 5
grands musées ils sont rassemblés au
cœur de la ville de Berlin il y en a
pour tous les goûts
et j'ai inclus aussi le Humble forum
dont j'ai parlé avant qui se trouve
aussi sur cette île s'est-il au musée je
dirais que c'est l'une des sols
aujourd'hui où vous pouvez découvrir
presque toute l'histoire de l'humanité
l'histoire de nos ancêtres
non
depuis 1999 Berlin a un immense
programme pour l'île au musée pour la
changer tous les bâtiments ont été
pendant la séparation de la ville assez
ignorée et il y a aussi un grand plan
pour collecter les musées entre eux par
une promenade archéologique
dans les prochaines années une entrée
principale pour ses musées
et le petit plus que nous avons en ce
moment car le musée de Pergame est en
train d'être rénové nous avons le
panorama qui est une image panoramique à
l'extérieur du musée qui est assez
intéressantes car elle explique toute
l'histoire de la cité de Pergame et
comment est arrivé tout cet héritage
culturel jusqu'en Allemagne
et en termes de tourisme est-ce qu'on a
une idée du le nombre de touristes qui
viennent chaque année visiter la
capitale allemande sauf
youtube
il est assez difficile de comparer les
chiffres de cette année avec ceux de
l'année dernière
nous ne pouvons pas le faire directement
car nous savons tout ce que l'année
dernière a été difficile
mais pour le moment en 2022 nous avons
les chiffres de Jean via Hamet car il
faut plus d'un mois et demi pour les
récolter nous avons
8,4 millions de nuités à Berlin c'est
35% de moins que notre année record en
les Français sont quatrième en termes de
nombre de touristes avec 170 unités
entre janvier et mai on récupère assez
bien l'Europe et le marché sur lequel on
récupère le plus vite c'est surprenant
mais les pays du Benelux avec les
Pays-Bas sont là de nos premiers marchés
car c'est facile de venir en train ou en
voiture
et pour terminer car le carbonet quelle
est la meilleure période pour venir à
Berlin on pense notamment au fait de
Noël
c'est très difficile comme question
parce que je pourrais commencer
maintenant avec
oui vous avez raison le marché de Noël
est un moment très agréable pour visiter
Berlin mais l'été comme aujourd'hui bon
il pleut mais nous avons des jours d'été
très chauds
et cet été nous n'avons pas moins de 90
événements dans toute la ville il y a
donc beaucoup à faire à l'extérieur et
même dans la vieille ville Anne from
jass j'ai vérifié quelques événements il
y a le festival de jazz un festival
gastronomique un festival de lumière au
moment où les jours commencent à être
plus court et que les nuits deviennent
plus longues
toute la ville est illuminée pendant une
semaine donc c'est toujours le bon
moment pour venir à Berlin après cela
dépend si vous venez chercher plus de
culture un style de vie pour y vivre ou
si vous êtes un fêtard donc ça dépend de
vous
tentation car le carboné de rien
[Musique]